con la llegada del Invierno más cerca
del gobierno francés anuncia que está
haciendo todo lo necesario para evitar
un racionamiento de energía entre sus
acciones trabaja para la puesta en
funcionamiento de las plantas nucleares
luego que un retraso en el mantenimiento
dejarás sin funcionamiento la mitad de
los 56 reactores que hay en el país
PDF se ha comprometido a reactivar todos
los reactores de este invierno
Seguiremos de cerca la situación con
actualizaciones semanales y estaremos
atentos a que se cumpla este cronograma
digamos
de una reunión especial del gabinete
sobre el suministro de energía de
Francia confirmó que las instalaciones
de almacenamiento de gas se encuentran
actualmente en un 92% con el objetivo de
estar completamente llenas para
noviembre Esta es una reserva abundante
pero si los próximos meses son más fríos
de lo esperado la situación podría
cambiar para ayudar a los consumidores a
soportar Los Altos precios el paquete
ayuda del gobierno francés por 65.000
millones de euros incluía recursos para
los más vulnerables subsidios de
combustible en las gasolineras y precios
de energía regulados aunque se esperaba
que el límite de precios llegará a su
fin en enero el gobierno ha insinuado
que esto podría extenderse nunca
jugaremos parte del aumento del precio
de la electricidad Este es el precio
máximo regulado lo hicimos el año pasado
y lo haremos este año y estos son los
elementos que discutiremos en las
próximas semanas
en Francia los precios de la energía han
subido a máximos históricos lo que
significa que uno de los principales
exportadores de Electricidad de Europa
ahora es un importador y es posible que
no pueda producir lo suficiente para
ayudar a sus vecinos europeos a buscar
alternativas al gas ruso